meine Damen und Herren und alle
dazwischen und außerhalb herzlich
willkommen zu diesem
exquisiten Adventskalender auspackvide
ich hätte eigentlich was schickeres
anziehen sollen als meine blöde
Sportjacke ne ich hasse trainingsanf
nein heute packen wir den Feinschmecker
Adventskalender von get voila aus und
bevor ich diese Marke zu oft nenne
dieses Video ist leider mal wieder nicht
gesponsert aber wir tun das ja trotzdem
hier sehr gerne und jetzt alle dieses
Video ist nicht gespons aber wir tun das
alle hier sehr gerne ich habe mir das
Ding sel gekauft ich kannte getwalla
nicht bevor ich diesen Adventskalender
gekauft habe was ist getwalla was ist
das den ich hatte halt Bock auf so ein
richtig schönen Feinschmecker
Adventskalender ich erwarte hier
Trüffelöl Kekse keine Ahnung ich weiß es
nicht Premium Tiefkühlgerichte in
Restaurant Qualität für jeden Tag okay
ja es ist so eine Mischung aus hello
fresh und dr ögar tiefkülpizza irgendwas
dazwischen nicht dass das irgendwie in
den Tiefkühler musste ne nee 170 €
entdecke eine festliche Reise durch
kulinarische Schätze mit dem get voil
Adventskalender da steht aber nichts
über wren Wert oder so ob man da
irgendwie was jetzt gut sparen kann ich
denke mal weil es eine Box ist spart man
schon was aber bei feinschmeckerchen na
hast du L auf willst du
mitmachen ne kannst dich einfach daneben
setzen und immer mal was probieren ne
ach komm lass uns do zusammen
spielen do zusammenpielen ich spiele
gerade ich spiele Youtuber wenn ihr
wollt dass ich mit Timo noch ein
Adventskalender auspacke schreibt in die
Kommentare eigentlich schuldig ich habe
ja gesagt jetzt solltest du auch mal ja
sagen optisch 10 von ze erinnert mich
ein bisschen an einen Zirkus ich weiß
nicht warum irgendwie hat das was
[Applaus]
zirkusmäßiges oh da hat sich Design
mäßig jemand richtig ausgelebt das zeige
ich euch einmal guck mal der ist so groß
wie das ganze
Bild ja Zielgruppe wer ich würde ich
jetzt schon sagen einfach people ne eine
Warnung falls ihr mich jetzt gleich
Milch Schokolade oder so essen seht ich
hoffe dass hier drin auch Schokolade ist
wir vergessen einfach mal ganz kurz dass
ich daavon Bauchschmerzen Krieg okay
danke man bringe mir Türchen Nummer 1 oh
muss ich noch selbst
holen kommen wir zum ersten Türchen oh
das sieht aus wie eine Handtasche das
ist eine kleine Handtasche das ist
kleine shopping bag Pierre marcolini
Brussels das sieht aus wie kleine
Butterstücke im Hotel was für
Feinschmecker warum müssen rich people
Sachen immer in so einem Design kommen W
hat sich das ausgedacht oh die schreiben
da sogar dass da Laktose drin ist oh
mein Gott sehen die Pralinen schön aus
was für eine süße die Preise diese
Schachtel kostet 11,90 € oh die haben
sogar ihren eigenen pralin
Adventskalender wir haben keine Ahnung
was das kostet wir denken mal es ist
teuer was könnte das
sein wie das
knuspert das ist so blätterkrokant aber
für rich
people kennt ihr diese blterkokantbächen
von Aldi so schmeckt das ich könnte mehr
davon essen sei ehrlich Türchen Nummer Z
ah okay das ist auch cool auf den
stachteln stehen die
Infos ja das ist bestimmt Feinschmecker
aber das ist Alkohol nee lass mal
Haselnuss waholder Gerhard Liebel aus
Bayern kommt das das
freimeisterkollektiv ist ein offenes
Netzwerk von herausragenden Brennern
führenden Gastronomen und Experten sie
setzen auf Tradition der Brennkunst in
kleinen handwerklichen Arbeit Betrieben
juhu
haselnussschnaps ich nicht wenn ihr alt
genug seid um Alkohol zu trinken dann
bitte in Maßen genießen und niemals
Alkoholkonsum
missbrauchen will eine Flasche Wein
[Musik]
u das ist was ganz
feines Türchen Nummer zwei es schmeckt
nach Haselnuss und es schmeckt nach
waholda und es schmeckt so als ob man
Wodka drüber gekippt hätte wieso finde
ich denn 15 16
3 Nummer D
hübsch oh mein Gott ich sehe schon die
ganze Zeit die Christstollen im
Supermarkt ich denke so ne Vanessa es
ist noch zu früh es ist zu früh du wirst
noch chrisstollen essen den müssen wir
probieren ne ministollen von
kaiserstollen dieses Rezept wurde von
Jans Ur Ur Großvater verwendet ja dann
hole ich mal ein Brett 1 Kog Stollen
kosten 30 € wir haben 3 dieses Teil
kostet 10 € ungefähr also der sieht
wirklich handgemacht
aus so
rum oh mein Gott der hat viel Zucker
drumrum also man kaut auf viel Zucker
der schmeckt so anders wie der
Christstollen von Haldi der hat auch
diese richtigen kangierten Früchte drin
hier z.B schmeckt heftig so heftig wie
halt ein Christstollen schmecken kann ne
Nummer 4 ob bitte nicht noch ein Schnaps
in Stroh eingepackt ist schon mal kein
gutes Zeichen nein es ist ein Glas Glück
gehabt ich fühle mich aber ehrlich
gesagt nach diesem Schnaps auch ein
bisschen das ist alles so handmade ich
dachte das ist ja also
ponso was ponsumarinade ponsoarinade von
jellyfish mitten auf der Schanze in
Hamburg liegt das stnerrestaurant
jellyfish Stefan Fed und sein Team
verzaubern hier ihre Gäste in
entspannter Atmosphäre mit erstklassiger
Fischküche extra für euch hat Stefan FE
mit seinem Team eine seiner Soßen zum
Genießen für kreiert die ponsu Marinade
eignet sich ideal zum Anrichten von
rohem wie gegrillten Fisch ich find es
irgendwie mega cool das so ein
Sternekoch einfach eine Marinade mit
seinem Team gemacht hat und die jetzt
hier so drin ist interessant ich lass
mich nicht
lumpen oh scharf aber lecker jetzt muss
ich das verwendenin kann man safe auch
richtig gut Tofu einlegen Stefan F du
kannst mich ja gerne mal einladen und
dann probiere ich mal dein Restaurant
aus Nummer
5 alles war wirklich so handverpackt das
sieht nach kommerzieller lindschokolade
aus von Rausch dunkle
edelkakaoschokolade seit über 100 Jahren
verkauft das Berliner
Familienunternehmen Rausch Schokolade in
feinster Qualität 484% ich weiß bei zart
bitterchokolade wie heißt das trennen
sich die Geister Balten sich die Geister
Balten sich die
Meinungen oh mein Gott ist das bitte
aber se fein das raus Schokoladenhaus
ist in Berlin sehr gut bewertet 4,6
Sterne bei
7664 Bewertungen muss aber sagen die
Schokolade hat auch sehr gut geschmeckt
Nikolaus wir halten uns kurz mal an den
Händen fest und hoffen dass da was
richtig cooles drin ist denn selbst wenn
man erwachsen ist ist Nikolaus noch ein
toller Tag und ihr solltet definitiv
euren Liebsten noch was in den Schuh
stecken ich sehe aber bei einen Kartons
viele haben so wie so eine Staubschicht
drauf ich glaube die waren lange
gelagert zwei fette Lebkuchen da kann
man schön Teilen original Nürnberger
Elisen Lebkuchen gebacken nach einer
Jahrhunderte alten Rezeptur hier googelt
der Chef noch selbst wie lange gibt es
Lebkuchen die Geschichte von Lebkuchen
begann vor Tausenden von Jahren einen
ersten schriftlichen Hinweis auf
Lebkuchen findet man um 350 vor Christi
doch schon die alten Ägypter haben
Kuchen mit Honig bestrichen und zusamm
gebacken und da ist kein Milch drin auch
noch einmal die schokoladenw lecky
schmecki oh Mutter ich freue mich auf
meinen Feinschmecker
Lebkuchen das hier ist immer noch
qualitätscontent also hier einmal der
Querschnitt sieht exakt gleich
aus aber Lebkuchen ist auch nicht gleich
Lebkuchen ne wenn ihr an so ein
Lebkuchenherz denkt das sieht ja nicht
drin so aus so nussig und stückig aber
traditionelle Nürnberger Lebkuchen aus
Berlin das war ein gutes Nikolaus
Türchen weil jetzt auch sehr Weihnachten
schreib Nummer sben warum ist hier Stroh
warum hast du eine Maske auf ja das
klingt wirklich nach so einem
feinschmeckerzeug geräucherte Lauch
showu Lauch schou von Papa Mame Tobias
Betz Küchenchef und gastronomischer
Leiter des zweine Restaurants Alexander
Hermann sowie sein food Scout Jörg
Oswald sind mehr als nur ein Team wir
sind Gegensätze die sich anziehen und
manchmal ausziehen scheiße das erinnert
mich an
iberast oh mein Gott ist halt genauas
was ich mir in Feinschmecker
Adventskalender vorstelle Nummer
das sieht ja wieder zuckersüß aus ne
aber ist das so Feinschmecker
Weihnachtsmarmelade wie lange gibt es
schon Marmelade die industrielle
Produktion von bitter orangenmmelade
begann in Schottland bereits
1797 und 150 Jahre später sitzt eine
Youtuberin und probiert
Weihnachtsmarmelade von ihrem spitzen
Messer hätte man das den Leuten damals
erzählt dann hätten sie gesagt was ist
YouTube die schmeckt überhaupt nicht süß
hä ich habe zu viel lebkuchengeschmack g
Mund das kommt gar nicht durch diese
ganzen weihnachtlichen Gewürze und
Früchte und was ist jetzt so tolles
daran Weihnachtsmarmelade von Garten
testdorf Gartenhaus testdorf fertigt
seit fast 20 Jahren erlesene Marmeladen
und Fruchtaufstriche an eine
preisgekrönte Marmelade vielen Dank bis
jetzt hatten wir Schokolade wir hatten
einen liör wir hatten Sojasoße eine stne
Soß chrisst lebung also es ist
eigentlich genau das was man so in einem
feinschmeckerkörbchen erwarten würde ich
bin gespannt was noch kommen es war mal
wieder so klar Türchen Nummer 9 ist ein
riesengroßes Türchen und Türchen Nummer
9 ist das beste Türchen denn es ist
meine Lieblingszahl wisst ihr welche
Zahl auch noch meine Lieblingszahl ist
eine Million und ich hätte gerne eine
Million
Abonnenten ich habe gesehen dass 57% von
den Leuten die regelmäßig meine Videos
schauen mich nicht abonniert haben kommt
gönnt einer Schwester das Abo ihr könnt
mich dann nächstes jah einfach
endabonnieren dann ma ich wieder andere
Sachen und dann wenn ich wieder
Adventskalender auspacke dann kommt ihr
wieder ist das nicht ein toller Deal oh
nein
oh
ja oh nein oh
ja die wohl coolsten cocktaildosen die
ihr jemals gesehen habt excuse me ich
bin im sipcub Premium Cocktails ready to
enjoy Alkohol bitte nur in Maßen
genießen und wenn ihr alt genug dafür
seid hier sieht man die Zutaten für
einen Margarita und einen Negroni
mittlerweile kennen wahrscheinlich alle
dieses
tiktok darauf hin habe ich mir mal einen
mrony in der cocktailb bestellt und fand
ihn so eklig ich werde den auch nicht
probieren das
ist ist den fand ich so schlimm und ich
habe ihn vor allem in so einer
Cocktailbar bestellt wo man so 12 € für
ein Cocktail bezahlt hat ich habe das
angeguckt ich habe fast geweint aber was
ich gar nicht so schlimm finde ist eine
gute Margarita ich kann mir aber nicht
vorstellen dass Margarita aus der Dose
lecker ist
cheers oh da Stint nach
Alkohol okay das ist nicht kalt da fehlt
Eis aber wenn das beides dabei dann ist
super dann schmeckt nach einer Margarita
inspiriert von der aperotivo Kultur
stellt das junge Unternehmen zipc aus
ber
alles aus Berlin best of Berlin hätte
man den nennen können fürs nächste Jahr
Leute Premium
Cocktails du das trinke ich später
mal Nummer ze und ich habe einen sitzen
aber wir hatten noch kein Trüffel Leute
wir haben etwas sehr Merkwürdiges
aufzuklären wo ist der Trüffel what
Steinpilz trüffelcreme ich bin richtiger
Feinschmecker das da muss Trüffel her
Steinpilze sind auch sehr teuer manchmal
kaufe ich getrocknete Steinpilze wenn
ich Bigos machen möchte und da wundere
ich mich immer wie teuer das ist aber
was macht man mit einer Steinpilz
trüffelcreme das mache ich nicht auf
Leute ich gehe mal jetzt davon aus dass
wir alle wissen wie Trüffel schmeckt
oder das ist bis 2025 haltbar wenn ich
das jetzt nicht öffne ich weiß nicht ob
ich Trüffel Steinpilz trüffelcreme
irgendwie in nächster Zeit brauche
deswegen lasse ich lieber geschlossen
Nummer 11 Piemont Tesa nussbox mein Gott
das sieht so schick aus
amazing Haselnuss und Schokolade das
wusste schon lange dass das eine gute
Idee ist einfach eine geröstete
Haselnuss und Schokolade
drumherum die Haselnuss ist noch
karamelisiert meine Fresse es ist lecker
sowas darf nicht in unserem Haus sein
ich gebe die schnell Timo dass der die
aufessen soll ausgezeichnet von der
Feinschmecker Gambero Rosso sowie mit
dem World pastry Star in Mailand zählt
die gemeiner konfisserie seit über 100
Jahren zu einem der renommiertesten
konditoreibetriebe Europas falls ihr
gemeiner kennt schreibt gerne in die
Kommentare ich liebe sie Halbzeit Nummer
12 und es ist so leicht rich people Tee
koffeinfrei love it das sieht irgendwie
aus wie übergroße Verpackungen 2013
gründete Jana Matteo und aproditi floru
die Premiummarke anasa Organics mit
Ihrem Unternehmen wollen sie die
Einzigartigkeit der griechischen Natur
und Tradition neu aufgreifen biologisch
angebaut und handgeepflückt von lokalen
Produzenten in den TE von anasa Organics
kommen nur die besten
Zutaten
13 och was ist das denn das sieht aus
wie die größte Praline der Welt die
längste ist ja schon
Duplo Konsum und materieller Wohlstand
ist das einzige was meinem Leben noch
einen Sinn gibt
Marzipan schön Liebe Marzipan so sieht
das Marzipan
[Musik]
aus fantastisch maripan auch wenn ich
gröber mag dieses mazipan ist so ganz
fein mazipan stn von waldkönigsberger
mazipan bereits lorio war hier schon
Stammgast ich hoffe irgendwann sagt es
ein Kaffee auch über mich Starbucks
selbst malahwanne war hier schon
Stammgast der PSL hat ihr besonders gut
geschmeckt die Manufaktur Wald gehört zu
Berlin chararlottenburg wie das Kaufhaus
des Westens 1947 gründete der
Konditormeister Paul Wald mit seiner
Frau die kleine mazipananufaktur Nummer
Timo wollte doch wissen wo der Rotwein
ist oh das ist kein Rotwein Essig
Zubereitung Dornfelder und Dattel Tunke
von langweinessig die Essig Manufaktur
aus der Falz wurde von dem gelernten
Koch Jen Jens Jens Michael Lang Jens
Michael Lang gegründet ja und dann hat
er sein eigenen Essig gemacht
Rotweinessig mit dattelsüße kann ich
aber nicht probieren deswegen
15 noch mehr Schnaps noch mehr Schnaps
morgens mittags abends ich will sauf
Alkohol sehr verantwortungsvoll trinken
der Deckel ist gleich Messbecher Gold
willly
Spirituosen
cheers ne das verstehe ich nicht
schnapskultur verstehe ich nicht ja
vielleicht nee das schmeckt doch nicht
das schmeckt nicht goldwilly von
scheibelbrennerei und kommst aus Berlin
nee aus dem Schwarzwald
1921 mit gerade mal 22 Jahre kaufte Emil
Scheibel den alten Schwarzwaldhof und
gründete dort die Emil Scheibel
Schwarzwald Brennerei hat auch Preise
bekommen Nummer
16 Stroh da lacht mein
Feinschmeckerherz ich habe ein sitzen
ich habe ein sitzen ich kann es nicht
mehr ich habe nicht mal was wirklich
getrunken ich kann nicht ich kann nicht
beschreiben ich habe das Gefühl ich habe
ein sitzen anyway geräuchert das Salz
gut dass S noch mal drauf schreiben dass
vegan glutenfrei und laktosefrei
ist oh mein Gott das Salz ist hier
überall hingeflogen das ist auf meine
ganze Hand geflogen was ist denn
hier h was war den da für ein Druck
drauf oh riecht das
Gut Schinken
Osterfeuer ein riesiges Lager das oh
mein Gott wie
[Musik]
krass
Timo ja riech mal dieses räuchersalz
heftig oder was
uii heftiges Raucharoma ne geil oder
boah riecht richtig richtig lecker
geräuchertes Salz von nobelhart und
schmutzig im Februar 2015 eröffnete
Billy Wagner mit Küchenchef Micha
Schäfer auf der Friedrichstraße Berlin
das Speiselokal nobelhart und schmutzig
ich glaube ich habe schon mal darüber
gesprochen also mit Freunden es war von
Beginn an Ihr Anliegen Berlin Lebens mit
aus ihrer Umgebung nahzubringen richtig
geiles Salz das werde ich benutzen und
mich jedes Mal freuen 17 irgendwie
schick und irgendwie auch ultra kitschig
das sieht lecker aus
oh Engel ohne Kopf ja schmeckt wie ein
Butterkeks mit Schokolade da ist ganz
viel Milch drin ein ganz kleiner Milch
und Sahne
und schokoladenengel von Johann von ilon
Johann kommt aus Berlin Spaß Handarbeit
wird hier groß geschrieben 2007
gestartet und ohne große finanziellen
Mittel für Maschinen entschied sich
Johann von ilon sein Feingebäck
traditionell mit der Hand zu backen ich
lieb das wenn Leute sich selbstständig
machen mit solchen Sachen ich weiß man
sollte nicht sagen oh früher war alles
besser aber die Zeit wo alles noch so
eine Wertigkeit hatte und alles noch so
ein bisschen mehr Handarbeit war es muss
schon auch cool gewesen sein auch wenn
wir technischen Fortschritt natürlich
super finden Nummer 18 in Nummer 18
befindet sich Glühwein
kräuterelixir ich kenne ja nur Glühwein
Teebeutel oder Glühwein gewürzsets seit
Jahrzehnten produziert diaglas in Ihrer
Apotheke althergebrachte Rezepturen
orientiert am deutschen Arzneibuch das
finde ich mega cool ich glaube ich werde
es für so ein Weihnachtsdinner
aufbewahren weil so ein Aperitiv mit
Champagner und so einen leichten
glühweingeschmack dazu
19 okay das sieht wieder aus wie jemand
hat das in seinem Keller selbst
zusammengebraut Aronia Aufstrich das ist
aber sehr flüssig mit t Hiti Vanille und
20 Jahre alten Portwein das ist so ein
richtig selbstausgedruckter Sticker Jens
ritmeier auch bekannt als der socengott
aus dem hohen Norden nahezu jedes Medium
hat schon über seine Küche und Soßen
geschrieben seine Küche zeichnet sich
vor allem durch den ständigen Wandel mit
der Natur aus im Rahmen seines
überraschungsmenüs bietet er immer nur
das an was in der laufenden Woche reif
geerntet wurde was hat das jetzt mit
seinem Aufstrich zu tun ja danke Herr
ritmeer ihr werdet wirklich überrascht
sein und wir sind in den 20
angekommen noch mehr Kekse uh sieht das
cool aus veratelle von arteminisa
nördlich von Rom in der bergstatt
la
lail befindet sich die kleine Manufaktur
namens
artemisa Waffeln die könnte ich aber
auch ganz leicht selber herstellen ich
habe nämlich so ein Waffeleisen mit dem
man diese Waffeln machen
[Musik]
kann es schmeckt wie die beste Eiswaffel
die ich jem gegessen hab da ist Kaffee
drin vielleicht werde ich ja doch noch
so eine feinschmeckermaus 21 also jetzt
kann uns nichts mehr überraschen jetzt
haben wir alles gesehen was ist hier für
meinen
Gaumen okay ich bin überrascht was ist
das denn das heißt Cavia
Roli wir können immer noch überrascht
sein Olivenöl Cavia in Zusammenarbeit
mit Sterneköchen natürlich wer ist hier
kein ständekoch mehr stellt das junge
spanische Unternehmen caviaroli
einzigartige Produkte aus der
Molekularküche her normalerweise sind
die Innovationen und hochwertigen
Kreation nur in der Spitzenküche zu
finden nicht umsonst sind sie
ausgewählter Partner des spanischen
Restaurants dis frut dem zweitbesten
Restaurant der Welt gibt es das beste
Restaurant was ist das beste Restaurant
der Welt frut Platz 2 Platz 1 zentral in
Lima Platz 40 Restaurant timraaue Berlin
hey ich habe dich in letzter Zeit viel
im Fernsehen gesehen lad mich doch mal
gerne ein bei dir zum Essen und das
nobelhart und schmutzig was wir auch
schon mit dem Salz hatten Platz 45 wisst
ihr was nächstes Jahr einfach mein
Content wird ich habe doch eh nicht so
viel zu tun bis ich nächstes Jahr wieder
Adventskalender auspacke ich fahre
einfach zu all den besten Restaurants
der Welt und ich fange bei Platz 50 an
das NN man eine Weltreise ja gut das
werde ich mir wahrscheinlich nicht
leisten können wir denken noch mal auf
dieser Idee rum ich muss das auf jeden
Fall probieren ich gehör zu den Leuten
die es lieben einfach so Olivenöl
zuaschen weil andere könn das eklig
finden Olivenöl kavia ich flipp
aus wie Bubble Leute es platzt auf und
es kommt Olivenöl raus crazy das finde
ich richtig cool 22 guckt mal Leute so
sieht Weingummi für reiche aus oh nein
das hätten sie reinschreiben können wenn
das Lakritz ist ist Weingummi und
Lakritz sind noch ganz verschiedene
Sachen so grünne mit so ganz leichten
roten
Punkten ich weiß nicht wie es
gleichzeitig nach Lakritz und nicht nach
Lakritz schmecken kann veganes
Fruchtgummi mit Limettengeschmack
umhüllt mit Kerbel und blaubeerpulver
wenn ich so Weingummi essen möchte dann
sollen das nim zwei soft sein dann will
ich da reinbeißen da soll süße kleprrige
Soße rauspritzen und fertig das ma das
das ich würde jetzt eigentlich gerne
sagen dass das das vorletzte Türchen ist
aber wir haben noch zwei vor uns 24 und
31 so Nummer 23 oh nein oh nein da ist
eine Flasche drin da ist eine Flasche
drin ich muss doch diesen Eierlikör
nicht probieren das ist doch wirklich
nicht
nötig
Eierlikör von horard wo einst die
Gaststätte Exil Stand befindet sich
heute das renommierte horwart ein
zweisterne Restaurant das eine
faszinierende Geschichte mit David Bowe
Max Frisch und reainer Werner Fassbinder
teilt umgeben von einem malerischen von
Weinreben umrangten Gartenzaun troh das
Restaurant im lebhaften B Lin
Kreuzberg ich glaube das ist sehr guter
erlikör ich schmecke der soll sehr gut
sein er schmeckt aber extrem nach Ei für
mich muss guter erlikör eher so nach
Sahne Vanille schmecken ich weiß unter
den Kenner ist das wahrscheinlich super
verpönt aber der schmeckt wie Ei in
deine Fresse das stimmt mega cool und
horard Restaurant ich versuch ganze Zeit
hier einfach restauranteinladung zu
bekommen horard lad mir dich ein es ist
Wein wenachten das 24 Türchen können wir
nun endlich aufmachen wir gehen zu
unserem Feinschmecker Adventskalender
wir müssen heute ein ganzes
Weihnachtsdinner zubereiten und hoffen
dass hier eine rettende Zutat drin ist
und nun frisch aus Berlin
importiert cool Hamburger goldmandeln
mit echtem Gold genauso stellt man sich
doch feinchmeckerkram vor eine Leckerei
mit Geschichte diese Weihnachten feiern
wir mit den goldmandeln der Famil
weltkamp seit über 200 Jahren sind sie
im zuckerwarenhandel tätig Oma janche
gründete 1821 den Betrieb und das dazu
gehörige Kaffee auf dem Hamburger Dom
wow bitte schmeckt gut die sind da ist
halt wirklich Gold dran
ne genau wie sie schmecken
müssen und so ein Highlight dass es
einfach vergoldet ist richtig cool
richtig cooles Türchen mega schönes Glas
sieht mega cool aus in diesem Kalender
gibt es ein Silvester wie cool ist das
denn ach
naürlich sekttradition Raumland Sekthaus
ein
Piccolo ja was braucht man an Silvester
Sekt zum Anstoßen das Raumland Sekthaus
steht an der Spitze des deutschen
Schaumweines bereits 1984 wurde der
erste Raumland Sekt kreiert heute ist
das renommierte Sekthaus aus dem
Rheingau bekannt für seine hochwertigen
Schaumweine die nach traditioneller
flaschengehrung hergestellt werden wir
und unsere getw Partner wünschen euch
ein guten Rutsch und ein frohes neues
Jahr oh mein Gott ich freue mich ich ihr
könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen wie sehr
ich mich aufs Neue Jahr freue wer zur
Zeit auch richtig emotional weil ich
jetzt mittlerweile weiß wann die erste
Schlüsselübergabe ist Timo und ich haben
vor d Jahren uns Gedanken gemacht eine
Wohnung zu kaufen durch Corona und dass
wir Geld angespart hatten haben wir es
einfach als den richtigen Zeitpunkt
empfunden auch wenn damals schon die
Zinsen so ein bisschen hochgegangen sind
und wir dachten oh vielleicht sind wir
schon zu spät dran und die Preise in
Berlin waren auch schon v vor dre Jahren
einfach nur abartig und dann haben wir
aber trotzdem uns dann da beraten lassen
und hatten Termine und haben richtig
Erwachsenen plötzlich spielen müssen und
dann hat das auch alles irgendwie
geklappt obwohl wir nichts in diesem
Bereich verstanden haben und dann wurde
halt gebaut und gebaut und gebaut und
ich bin so oft zur neuen Wohnung
vorbeigefahren um zu gucken wie weit sie
sind und habe die Baustelle gesehen und
jetzt ist es einfach endlich im neuen
Jahr soweit dass wir umziehen und ich
kann gar nicht früh genug erwarten dass
Weihnachten kommt dass dann Silvester
kommt wir anstoßen wir uns aufs Neue
Jahr freuen können und dieses neue Jahr
wird so verrückt alleine weil etwas
passiert worauf wir seit di Jahren
warten dass diese Wohnung fertig wird es
ist crazy und ich habe da richtig Bock
drauf ich bin seit paar tagen deswegen
ein bisschen emotional ich kann es kaum
abwarten so jetzt geht's aber nicht um
meine Wohnung oder ums neue Jahr es geht
um getw
boah dafür geh ich in die Hölle dieser
Kalender kostet 170 € das heißt wir
sprechen hier schon von einer Zielgruppe
die sich sowas leisten muss und wenn man
sich das leisten kann dann finde ich das
einen richtig coolen Kalender man hat
wirklich jeden Tag was Neues zu
entdecken man bekommt Soßen und
eierliköre von irgendwelchen
sternekochchen zubereitet man bekommt
leckeres Gebäck was weihnachtlich ist
was aber auch teilweise dann nicht ganz
so weihnachtlich ist man bekommt mal
hier ein Cocktail oder ein Schnaps das
ist richtiger feinschmeckerkalender also
es hat kein Türchen so wirklich
enttäuscht außer die Weingummis war
nicht scheiße und der necroni den hoffe
ich noch irgendwie loswerden zu können
aber ja da waren auch absolute
Highlights drin wie Olivenöl Rauchsalz
Gewürz Mischung goldmandeln ich bin
absoluter Fan von diesem Kalender 170 €
macht das Ganze natürlich zu einem ja
nobleren Luxusartikel ich freue mich
einfach dass ich mich jetzt D
dururchnaschen konnte und ja ich hoffe
ihr hattet ein bisschen Spaß beim
zuschauen und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten Adventskalender wieder was in
wahrscheinlich zwei Tagen sein wird bis
dann